>> Okay. And it points out a choice that you have as a specifier here.
We could if we were given a a vector of length three and a vector of length 10,
say no they, they don't have the same elements and remember by same elements as,
we're talking about the same number of occurrence as. Or,
we could treat it as a pre-condition, okay? And say that the lengths must be
the same in order for us even to apply same elements as, as a function, and
that's the choice that we're going to, we're going to make here. Okay, so
remember that the vertical line is used for cardinality or
length. And the cardinality of x must be equal to the cardinality of y.
Now we're talking here about first order logic. We're not talking about
a programming language. So equals means equal. It doesn't mean a sign to or
anything else. We don't have to worry about anything like the C or
Java where we'd have to use two equals, symbols in order to designate equality.
So we're just going to say that the length of x equals the length of y,
and that's the precondition for, same elements as. Now, going back to
when we first asked the question to state in, in English, what it means
for the output to be the assorted version of the input, we said things like each
element in x must be found in y, each element of y must be found in x, and
the number of occurrences the elements in x must be the same as the number of
occurrences the elements in y. And we could take that and we could
go through the stage of writing out each of those parts in first order logic.